I this is your whole act Albert
Einstein's a genius what do you think
Bill um I don't is he is he is really
really he couldn't even get a decent
haircut what's that his mustache he
couldn't trim it the guy who had ad he
was just you know he how'd you come up
with your stuff Albert oh I sit on the
couch and think for 20 minutes ooh
that's so hard I'm going to do your
[__] act go
ahead why the chick
cross the
road oh you wake up in the morning and
you brush your teeth billur takes it up
the butt you wake up in the morning and
you brush your hair Bill b takes it up
the butt it's as easy as one 2 three
simple as
ABC you wake up in the morning and you
take a breath of air Bill Bird takes it
up the butt up the butt up the butt up
the
butt that's my ACT hey